bonjour patrick vits seria bonjour votre
invitation et merci à vous d'être avec
nous en direct dans cette matinale d'air
france alors la saison touristique
évidemment c'est votre préoccupation
faire revenir les touristes aux
étrangers mais aussi les les touristes
français alors oui c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour pour le tourisme français
à la fois pour les professionnels vous
savez que le secteur du tourisme a été
un des secteurs les plus impactés en
fait part par l'écho vide et c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour les touristes
étrangers qui vont pouvoir à nouveau
venir en france et on sait que la
clientèle étrangère c'est un élément
extrêmement important de l'économie du
tourisme
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle qu'il y ait
des déplacements autorisés sauf que on
s'y retrouve pas tellement un chacun y
va de ses impératifs tests pcr
vaccination c'est pas trés harmonisée au
niveau européen est ce que vous vous y
retrouvez vous alors oui c'est vrai que
donc d'abord toutes les restrictions en
france seront levés pour la fin du mois
de juin donc donc il faudra continuer
bien sûr respecter tous les gestes
barrière tous les protocoles sanitaires
vous savez qu'un pass sanitaire va
permettre aussi de se déplacer à la fois
entre les différents pays européens
et puis de pouvoir assister un certain
nombre de manifestations pour plus de
1000 personnes donc en france donc c'est
pas encore très bien harmonisé des les
choses se préparent petit à petit il ce
qu'on espère c'est qu'il y aura le plus
d'harmonisation possible pour que le
plus d'aucun puisse venir à nouveau en
vacances dans notre pays est-ce qu'en
france vous trouvez qu'il ya
suffisamment de de lisibilité sur ce
plan de levée de restrictions
alors ce qu'on sait c'est que les
dernières enquêtes qui viennent d'être
faites notamment celle de l'ipsos et de
l'alliance française montre qu' il ya en
fait une très forte appétence à partir
du français volent partir en vacances
et à tout prix on le voit aussi dans les
budgets sont prêts à dépenser autant
sinon plus que ce qu'ils ont dépensé
l'année dernière ou en 2019 et que ce
sera essentiellement un était franco
français c'est à dire qu'on va surtout
rester comme l'année dernière en 2020
d'ailleurs en france avec peut-être une
ont envie d'aller au port la mer on a
envie de soleil et on retrouve là des
valeurs traditionnelles de de se
retrouver entre amis au bord de la mer
quand on veut qu'on avait dans les
années antérieures
oui c'est bien les besoins blanc rouge
comme le prône le gouvernement qui a
lancé hier son sa grande campagne pour
attirer les touristes
absolument ça s'inscrit tout à fait dans
la campagne de communication que lance
le gouvernement il faut dire que ça va
être une compétition aussi très forte
entre les pays puisque tous les pays
vont vouloir garder en fait leurs
touristes chez eux et que d'ailleurs le
gouvernement est en train d'étudier les
possibilités pour les français le parti
hier hors europe
vous savez qu'il ya un système de
couleurs qui n'est pas encore tout à
fait en place mais qui permettra de
guider les touristes vers les pays qui
sont qui posent le moins de problème est
qui et qui pourront accueillir des
touristes
alors vous parlez des pays qui
pourraient poser des problèmes en france
on est quand même à des niveaux assez
élevés de de contamination même si sa
baisse progressivement dans dans les
services de réanimation la
grande-bretagne d'ailleurs n'est pas sûr
du tout de permettre à ses concitoyens
de manière offrant sans pour l'instant
alors effectivement le passage du ter
qui doit être mis en place doit
permettre de réduire en fait les délais
de septèmes qui est certaine qui peuvent
exister avec certains pays alors on sait
que du côté la clientèle britannique qui
pèse quand même casse pour cent du de la
fréquentation totale des touristes ça va
être plus difficile
on attend les décisions qui seront
prises avec l'allemagne faut voir qu'il
ya beaucoup d'initiatives aujourd'hui
qui sont mis en place pour ce notamment
au corridor sanitaire est ouvert sur un
certain nombre de destinations je pense
à l'espagne
par exemple aux îles baléares ou bien un
lit de djerba où on a mis en place en
fait des corridors totalement sécurisée
pour que les touristes puissent partir
donc la situation est en pleine
évolution
ce qui se prépare aujourd'hui en tout
cas c'est de répondre à un fort besoin
de dépassement et de voyage qu'ont les
français à ce fort besoin de déplacement
il a lieu déjà à partir de demain
puisqu'il ya un grand week end de pau en
perspective est-ce que c'est
annonciateur de ce qui va se passer cet
été selon vous oui absolument je pense
que c'est un week-end de rodage en
quelque sorte pour se préparer à la
suite les il ya un besoin les français
sont restés enfermés on le voit très
bien dans dans les enquêtes et ils ont
envie en fait de partir même si on voit
bien aussi que les réservations
certes continue d'augmenter y aura
beaucoup de réservations de dernière
minute
on sait que deux français sur toi n'ont
pas encore organiser leurs séjours d'été
et que tout ça le conte vide est passé
par là en train de nouveaux
comportements qui font que on se prépare
au dernier moment il ya des conditions
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui nouvelles qui
sont proposés à la clientèle puisque on
peut annuler réservé dans des conditions
tout à fait exceptionnelle aujourd'hui
donc c'est quelque chose qui est en
mouvement en fait
est ce qu'on peut dire que les cet été
sera différent quand même de l'été
précédent où il ne faut pas relâcher les
gestes barrière alors déjà il faut
maintenir les gestes barrières parce que
l'objectif c'est d'éviter une quatrième
vague c'est ça quand même l'enjeu temps
qu'il va falloir continuer à respecter
les protocoles sanitaires
la distanciation ça c'est indispensable
mais ce qui est nouveau c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya une citation quand
même à pousser les français à partir en
vacances on va pouvoir faire accueillir
de la clientèle étrangère pour rappeler
quand même que la clientèle étrangère
est essentiel pour le fonctionnement du
tourisme ne serait-ce qu'au niveau des
dépenses moyennes qui sont plus élevés
même si les clientèles lointaines pour
l'instant et bien sans doute se faire
attendre
que ce soit les clientèles asiatiques ou
bien les clientèles amérique et bien sûr
la vaccination est un enjeu majeur pour
vous alors qu'aujourd'hui elle est à
tous absolue la vaccination est le passe
à lithaire donc vont jouer un rôle très
important
le je crois que le parlement a voté hier
soir la mise en place du pass sanitaire
donc c'est un élément important pour
sécuriser à la fois les déplacements et
les destinations
oui le pas salutaire qui a failli ne pas
passer on l'a vu hier soir on va en
parler dans ce journal merci beaucoup
patrick et sérieuse merci pour toutes
ces précisions dans la matinale verte et
france